of the universe the adventures and all
the heroes are gonna have to pull out
all the stops to stop this man super
super villain exactly but you know what
we've heard some rumors here - yeah we
heard many rumors which wine are we
gonna start with well oh it's not about
the film we're gonna keep it easy on
everybody but we heard that some people
actually have been here for a long
period of time from I've heard yesterday
anybody ever since yesterday or is that
just a joke seriously
yesterday what time what time
thank you you waited outside from 9 p.m.
oh my goodness can anybody meet beats 90
anyone but being on him what time
[Music]
where you are today you are gonna meet
the celebs on the purple carpet it is
worth the wait ladies and gentlemen but
we officially opened the gate under now
but thousands were already here made
about 3,000 people this morning at the
gate - 7 a.m. yeah and now the tickets
are sold out in his school now but not
only is this a massive spectacle of a
fan event I mean this is one of the
biggest things they have ever ever ever
done and that's why Marina Bay Sands is
gonna look absolutely spectacular later
on if you don't give away too much yeah
I know I hate it but I also want to say
some of you some of the best fans of the
world according to Joe Russo are
actually in Singapore is this true
yeah it'll still sell - confident in
that Niki yeah oh but but not everyone
here is from Singapore did it hands up
if you flew in from another country just
to be here Wow ok we're gonna go by the
South from Singapore big surprise
Malaysia
[Applause]
from all over the world how about this I
have to do the shameless plug from my
cuppa buy a puppy eyes
everywhere we go there's a Filipino
everywhere I love it I always feel
welcome she was teaching me some
language yesterday which I won't repeat
on stage right oh good good but this is
how big this is we appreciate you've
been here a long time we're gonna be
doing a couple fun things up here before
the celebrities come but it's so
important that you have your phones
charged and that you are connected to
social media right that's right because
you want you to take pictures and I want
you to hashtag and tag us throughout the
night we've got Avengers SG hashtag I
said infinity war Marvel Singapore and
of course arena bass stands this is what
you have to do believe me when the show
and we get to the main event you're
gonna want to be taking pictures so
throughout the night if you hear
something you say something you want to
put it up do so okay go downstairs
actually take some photos with us some
people right yes I am okay fine fine all
right so Bobby's gonna do that we talked
about 10 years in the making it's kind
of like everything is coming together
with Avengers infinity war we know that
they did film two movies back to back
okay but it's all coming together some
of your favorite superheroes are all
coming together we cannot wait for those
they know next who knows how big this is
gonna be because you know what even the
actors themselves we've been told have
not read the full script they have not
even seen the film all right they have
not seen the film they may have seen the
trailer but they have not seen the film
so ten years is a big big celebration
another thing we're celebrating is ten
years of Marvel Studios right here in
Singapore they're gonna do it in a
massive way because Marvel and the Walt
Disney Company Singapore is so excited
to announce Marvel Studios 10 years of
Heroes it is going to be a cutting-edge
exhibition this is going to be using of
the art audio-visual technology
immersive media it's gonna transport all
you fans super fans if you're not a fan
yet you're gonna be a fan by the end of
tonight of the Marvel heroes and Marvel
Universe okay and that's happening right
there you see that beautiful building
there that is the art Science Museum
this is a place that really knows how to
put an exhibit together okay and that
exhibit runs from the 9th of June to the
30th of September and those tickets have
already gone on sale okay so if you want
those tickets you want to see what it's
like coming to life go they're starting
to Bobby what are you doing Nick tip
down your tickets or photos and guess
what I have a pair of tickets to that
exhibition actually with me right now
already who wants a pair of tickets
come on I can't hear you who wants a
pair of tickets I
got this guy right here what's your name
cha-dol okay this is a two-part question
if you get it right two tickets of yours
and which is the last infinity stone
that Thanos is looking for
which one right what color is the soul
stone
which one is it oh boy
if you're right pair of tickets of yours
I
might have some tickets later on tonight
but the meantime thank you guys I'll see
there just a bit okay so more tickets
coming your way that's gonna be an
absolutely phenomenal exhibition guys to
make sure you see that at the art
exhibit I just wanted to say starting to
get the butterflies in the tummy because
I've been told by my producer that we
are less than an hour away from the
celebrities arriving who knows they
might either come in early because they
realize to have a thousand people is a
big deal okay so I'm getting a little
nervous but as we celebrate this
phenomenal film coming out and you guys
coming out in style I'm wondering is
there anyone here who is celebrating a
birthday today
or tomorrow a yesterday
there's some famous by the a theater
we're going to write over here Nikki
right there yes James right right there
there they are so do you have a birthday
wish have you got a birthday wish in
your head yes we're good about we're
about to make your wish come true all
7000 people at Marina Bay Sands are
going to wish you a happy birthday can
we do that for them they're gonna give
done let's get our tops on ladies and
gentlemen you go for it make the
opposite on this one cuz I don't have
the pipes for it hey everyone just sing
along with me we're gonna do it in
English sorry to the rest of our media
but most people know this song okay
[Music]
you hopefully you enjoyed that's just
special for you guys Wow why do I bring
this up they're like what a brand of
good what a very right new girl I bring
this up cause it's a celebration and
we're just wishes wishes are special
we've all made it at some point in our
life right actually my wish is coming
true right now which is to be able to
host this I have been a Marvel fan for
years it's collecting comic books when I
was 12 years old yes and seeing all the
movies actually be here on stage and who
looks like Tony's today I hope you
see I totally enjoy the Tony Stark for
that yeah see we are a fan see your wish
is coming true as it is but you know
what have you heard of make-a-wish
foundation anybody you look around oh
you sure y'all probably have heard of
make-a-wish Foundation if you have it
it's a phenomenal charity and what they
do is they grant life-transforming
wishes to children who are suffering
from critical illness right Bobby that's
right now whether it's flying a plane
and you're forming one race driver or
being a superhero the benefits of a wish
are actually tangible yeah in fact
science is proving that a child's wish
that's come true I should I said never
gonna prove it's in Hope positive
emotions and health-related quality of
life this is why Bobby and I cannot wait
to introduce you to these children they
are all beneficiaries of make-a-wish
Singapore and they're real little heroes
these guys are real little heroes in
their Nicanor illness right they've come
out strong they've drawn strength from
the wishes that they've made and it's
come true and they've got a brighter
future ahead of them they are amazing
absolutely and you know what Nikki
yesterday's little heroes completed the
five missions of the Avengers Academy
okay the five missions the five missions
of the Avengers Academy with none other
than Iron Man himself Robert Downey jr.
they met in they not with them oh yeah
with them they are now honorary Avengers
incredible so with that we would love it
if they come down and when they come
down that purple carpet that you show
them some love and support as the
honorary Avengers the awesome fighters
who are in it to win it ladies and
gentlemen get these kids around the
balls come on down
[Applause]
oh
yes
it's gonna take a lot of Avengers to
beat Panos
[Music]
if you like to be a superhero to a
make-a-wish child is part of what we
stand for 29th of April log on to make a
wish Oregon history today to see how you
can make a child's dream come true
awesome you guys we love having you here
if you're taking pictures of these
honorary adventures and awesome
superheroes guys make sure you're
hashtagging at 8 w little heroes
little heroes
okay so we're gonna pat down and see if
we can chat to them if we can get to
them before they get to the end of the
carpet let's join a few people I want to
find out about the missions by bishops
revolutions think it's not easy to be an
event
[Music]
hello guys how we doing here are you
guys excited for tonight
so what's your name
like you know how are you
we decided to meet Iron Man himself
Robert Downey jr.
what did you guys do what can you say
anything about the mission at all what
did you have to do you had five of them
you're so secretive I know you guys over
here wanted to talk to me earlier I'm
coming over here let's go dude he's like
people think what I said everything I
can't tell you the top secret mission
this guy this guy right here told us it
was challenging come on tell us what you
did you got to meet Robert Downey jr.
I'm excited meet Robert Downey jr.
because I
repeat Downey jr. because he's my
boy as bad he is yes he is but what
about the missions I'm serious I'm not
gonna stop I'm a journalist okay so tell
me one of the five missions you had to
cook a couple come on come on what do
you have to do
did you all complete it did you all
manage to finish this mission yes all
right let's get the victory pose for yes
okay let's ask which another mission do
you tell me whatever other ition is
a
hope smash what did you do what did you
smash as the Hulk
you smash cups and did he help you did
he help you did he go through this with
you
with the Hulk with a Hulk fist Wow nice
well you guys are fantastic you got to
meet all of them or at least Ironman
before any of these guys do so you're
very very VIP let's hear it one more
time for the kids from make-a-wish
Foundation their dream came true
and I am got something to do just a
little bit of a hey hey hey was that was
that was stopped with our super pants
out over here how about some prizes do
you want to win some prizes maybe I
don't know yeah always leave my
infantile Roy rice got the gauntlet open
it up Annette hey guys awesome so here
we go we're gonna start getting away
that's a president of a way here we go
go for Nikki and I would say I would say
if you struggle maybe someone next to
you can help out let's just try to be
nice okay we'll start with this who
answer first
okay I'm gonna ask you who are the six
founding members of the Avengers I mean
I don't know this but come on have a
thought think and here we go Iron Man
Captain America like wait oh okay yes
what's you whoa where are you from
Thomas have you go well this it's great
um I'm Nicolas from Singapore
I've been putting a movies since ten
years ago so from the first Ironman
you've been watching the end is just
getting better and better what are you
most excited about with the infinity war
Avengers if anyone I think it's like
watching all the heroes come together
from the guardians of the galaxy to and
all the Avengers on earth is there a
particular showdown you'd really like to
see all right watch The Avengers in the
guidance of galaxy beat down Thanos yeah
bring in for that for being awesome
Nicolas enjoy that okay and I can't
you're gonna see them right down here
awesome Bobby over to you you've got
fans too late I do actually I'm over
here in the front of the stage hello
guys thanks boy
[Applause]
okay I got a little Iron Man right here
what's your name I
mean you can lift the mask up it's
making you like Tony Stark right now oh
yeah how are you
are you excited for the movie
okay no Amelia I have a prize giveaway
are you a big Avengers fan
okay that's good enough it's not God
this question I mean he did start the
Avengers after all of course he was the
first film but here we go which Marvel
film did Thanos first appearance
most credit is both greatest a of
Avengers
[Music]
st. Emilia you're absolutely right the
Avengers
[Applause]
there you go okay back to you Nikki okay
so I'm on the other side over here I
don't know if you can see me yes ah here
hello I can see it if you're right over
there you guys want to make some noise
he's not you're like literally on a
massive screen yes yes okay but who here
can actually answer a hard question the
things they kind of got it you all of
you uh all of you we can all answer
something combined papaya chambray from
the Fela pants okay all right this is a
hard one to not put us to shame there's
like millions of us around the world
okay
you got the gauntlet Miguel from the
Philippines and
who came here with you today are you
here on your own I'm here with other
Filipinos
I'm also really Pina hello young okay we
love Manny Pacquiao okay here we go who
are Captain America's five team members
in Captain America Civil War
really do you guys want to help chime it
five team members at Captain America
yes scarlet wig
vines
Falcon
Hawkeye
and black widow
[Applause]
you always testing you it was
[Laughter]
my choice for being so supportive well
done it because okay we've got something
for you here that we're gonna throw it
over to Bobby he made it he made it
thanks for being awesome help do not
yeah alright I got a hard question over
here who's a bad of the black panther
who is a really big fan I need to know
this guy right here
what's your name sir
yeah me okay
this is a hard question
who is the leader
Jabari tribe I'm black
you're right in Baku is correct
my friend
hey you know what Bobby was so funny and
do her hats asking that question
everyone he was like oh come on let's go
easy
you're in the superfan section
done here okay see this if things on
that easy you can find this very easy so
who is gonna answer this next question
for a prize
yes where are you from Megan look at
your look at yourself on the screen
where are you from what's your name my
name is Alexandra I came from China
thank you so much
okay so who did you come here with
tonight and how long did you have to
wait to be here with the super famous
[Music]
with your husband now honey that's love
3 a.m. ain't nobody doing that for me
yeah okay so are you both massive fans
who are your favorites
so do I get mine they're mine you're
gonna be haven't opened any
Cumberbatch's coming here
keep your yourself your torso Nikki okay
sorry sorry her husband's also here we
have to play play cool right what's your
husband's name what do you what are you
who are you
sorry ah who are you
jeongsu okay who's your favorite of all
the heroes
[Applause]
that's okay we're gonna stick with the
ladies because they know what they're
talking about okay all right it's okay
we love you anyways we are gonna move on
okay go look at my screen guys it's not
fair not fair what was the name of the
group of mercenaries who raised
star-lord
you got it thank you for helping our
well done and enjoy tonight you guys
wonderful to meet you we've got
something for you Bobby over to you okay
go and spread around a bit yeah over
here we got some big fans right here I'm
Karen Gillan
let's see who wants answer to the
question this one's sort of easy if
you're a Captain America fan who's a
Captain America fan here
[Applause]
well that I'm not hearing the noise
who's a Captain America band I
got this guy right here what's your name
Oh
Charles were you from
jobs okay this question should be easy
for you then Charles if your accountant
America fan what material makes Captain
America's shield
[Music]
you're right
well you want to install you know right
and of course we can talk about the
comics version of it but we won't do
that right now will we I see oh don't
play without me okay well that's good
that's good everyone seduced yes yes -
do you make it yes okay I make it harder
I don't know I'm not quite gonna go hard
on these guys but okay you must be a
super fan tell us who you are where
you're from who came with you today and
yeah see how the cameras right there at
HD HD I know very close sorry so do you
okay ah Cheers so tell us who you want
who you're here with your friends
so who are your buddies say with their
names and all that I see is over there
he's over there
fantastic
okay so I'm gonna give you a chance to
win a prize here we go this one you
probably know what is the name of Tony
Stark's personal bodyguard
okay
y'all see all the most yeah good you got
it well done
absolutely okay we've got something for
you I'm gonna throw it back to Bobby all
right I'm okay I've got another question
can we complain here who watched Ant Man
Wow not too bad man fans here we see
this girl right here look like an F
ampad
what's your name
although are you problem
okay that's good good hopefully you're
doing well in school all right so Ella
here's a question for you now I'm gonna
give you a pair of tickets of the
exhibition if you get this correct
okay
what is the name of the scientist that
invented ant-man suit
now it's so fast oh my gosh okay correct
you are a big fan here you go
congratulations tickets to the
exhibition
alright I've got one more question to
give away here
let's see where are you going
let's see you know what should we test
the media just see how good they are
[Applause]
these we got this guy here in the most
colorful jacket I've ever seen in my
life
what's your name
pretty good
what is the name of the bridge
connecting Asgard to Earth
you are right it is the Bifrost
congratulations given the prize see the
immediate know some answers thanks to
you guys right over there all right
Nikki I'm heading over to you and we
know go to explore home right now is
he's all my friends
you know what should we ask one more
question should we ask one more question
again hey tweet where are you where are
you hey I mean Nick you have an ask one
more question if you don't mind no okay
okay go ahead one more question one more
question okay look at this I
know you do
okay aunt
do what you think about Hawkeye at all
you know anything about Hawkeye
what's his real name
well that's star-lord
first part
we got a room because the celebs are
coming down
[Applause]
hello hello what's your name
Jeremy okay what is Hawkeye his real
name
what's his first name you're right Clint
Barton congratulations
okay great stuff you guys are well done
Bobby okay I think we're warming
everybody up because it it's coming down
so what you're about to experience
tonight and where we're trying to warm
you up and get you excited because
believe me some crazy things are gonna
happen here Marina Bay Sands but the
thing is this entire spectacle and
you'll know just how big when you
experience it tonight could not happen
without the love and the support of
these two incredible gentlemen who are
about to hit the purple carpet so when
you hear me announce their names please
show them some love and support right
back entering the purple carpet our
executive vice president of the Walt
Disney Company South Asia mr. Mahesh
summit
Marina Bay Sands mr. George to knezovich
come on down
[Applause]
and as they make rate to the purple
carpet and actually throughout the night
as well as our celebs who cool down
we're going to take a quick break so
that the media have a chance to
interview them without our interruption
in the meantime as you see these cameras
we also have drones tonight if you see
yourself there please wave please wait
but as you can see mr. George - there's
an inch coming down and mr. fish
survived
[Applause]
alright folks as they're coming down the
purple carpet it is time for a fancam
I'll be saying this a couple times
tonight fancam image so
here we go
[Music]
if you see yourself eyes
thank you for making this event possible
gentlemen
all right
[Music]
a spicy
[Applause]
[Music]
there is daily joy
Thank You teacher
[Music]
[Applause]
all right folks so soon we aren't going
to be hearing from George and Mahesh
hi you guys doing okay looking good what
are you saying looking family good Wow
okay so just wanted to ask you a couple
questions actually first first note is
really this LED wristband I cannot
stress enough if you have it somewhere
in your pocket please make sure you've
got it on in fact let's do a little bit
of a practice on my count of three we
are going to say Avengers Assemble and
we're gonna put our wrists together up
our arms up can we do that you just want
to make sure that you've got it only if
you've got the wristbands have you got
it on
okay you know what to say Avengers
Assemble on the count of three one two
three
fantastic if you can do that for us
later on believe me it's gonna be an
even better show that we've got planned
I believe it's gonna knock your socks
off okay so one thing I wanted to say is
which one of these celebrities are you
most excited to meet
[Applause]
okay
for now I did promise that we would meet
these two gentlemen up close and
personal again without them this would
have been possible just like Nick Fury
brought together the Avengers so please
show some love for the executive vice
president of the Walt Disney Company
south asia mr. Mahesh summit and the
president and CEO of Marina Bay Sands
mr. George Tennessee bench
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
we're so pleased that you could be here
tonight this is a very special event for
us I think that it's it's quite
commendable of you that you've been here
in the thousands since before we even
open the doors this morning at 7:00 a.m.
there's 4,000 of you out here right now
there's another 3,000 people in our
exhibition hall who's going to be
watching this event by a live simulcast
and so the energy that you brought to
the building today is really exciting
and we appreciate your support and it
just gives us more incentive incentive
to bring more events like this to to
Singapore so thank you very much for
coming out I
also want to say thank Disney and the
stars and the producer and director and
everybody else who's here as part of the
team putting this event together with
our great staff from Marina Bay Sands
because this is a very complex event to
put together and I think you're really
going to be quite excited by it because
you're going to see something tonight
that has never happened at Marina Bay
Sands before and as Robert Downey jr.
has said in the media here in Singapore
this week you never repeat yourself even
if you're successful you keep trying to
do new things and be even more creative
and that's what we're trying to bring to
you tonight so thank you very much the
Disney also our partner in this event
the fifth time that we've done something
with this thing we're starting to work
very very closely together and
anticipate all the needs that we have to
stage a great event like this and we're
also neutrally pursuing the goal of
Singapore to establish this market as a
destination and a hub for the greatest
entertainment in the world so with that
thank you once again for being here
tonight we hope you enjoy yourself and
please come back and visit us again soon
at Marina Bay Sands they're not like to
turn it over to my friend and colleague
from this day Rakesh who's going to give
you a few comments as well
[Applause]
as big a fan as all of you are so I've
come here not just as a representative
of the Walt Disney Company but as a fan
of the Marvel Universe over 18 films in
10 years and this is the most
anticipated film of all times Avengers
I'm delighted to share and celebrate
with all of you at the Walt Disney
Company we are all about the fans the
communities and the spirit of
storytelling it's amazing how Marvel has
resonated even in this part of the world
primarily thanks to legendary
superheroes with great emotional
undercurrent so you know it's fantastic
to be in this venue I'd like to time
George and the Marina Bay Sands for
letting us do an event like this with
all of you and celebrated in the spirit
of what the Walt Disney Company is about
so without further ado I'm going to stop
talking and the only way we can get our
talent on is if you scream really loudly
Avengers Assemble you know that so go
for it repeat after me Avengers Assemble
thank you thank you very much George
tenacity appreciate it again for
bringing this all together and sorry yep
yep got it okay okay guys my producer is
telling me in my ear that we're about to
go live around the world in Facebook in
ten seconds so these parents are all
around so you know we got a pump up
Singapore pop up Avengers infinity war
count down with me in five
[Applause]
my name is Nikki Mueller we are here for
the heavily anticipated event I would
say off the year it's Marvel Studios
Avengers infinity war coming hot and
heavy on the 25th of April 4,000 fans
and media here at the event Plaza
[Applause]
exhibit hall a with my fantastic co-host
Bobby Tinelli Bobby are you down there
what's going on how is it
hello the game I'm an expo hall Avery
debates and these are our fans
make some noise everyone
[Applause]
Wow
I'll tell you what Nikki you got some
great fans out there at the event area
but right now I have to say our fans and
Expo Holly might be louder thanks to the
noise
[Applause]
that's good I love in that I'm loving
the energy over there but I have to say
anything 4,000 people over here could do
a little bit better what do you think
[Applause]
Wow
I only showed you what
come over to the other part
come on guys make some noise make some
noise
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about Nikki
all right I think
I'll give you one more from over here
and then I'll let you take it over the
typical 85 make you look bad people
they're great everywhere Bobby both of
these honestly we couldn't have asked
for anything more special tonight all
right Bobby what's going on over there
looks okay so right now we're at expo
hall a-and I told all the fans here we
have a surprise for them
because you guys are going to see Robert
Downey jr. benedict cumberbatch Guerra
kill it before anybody else
[Applause]
so let me explain what's gonna happen
right now in a few minutes I'm through
those black curtains the cars are gonna
come through here they are going to stop
right here and
you get to see them before everybody
else does
are you guys excited
[Music]
are you inside
so Bobby do you have some super fans
over there we'd like to meet some
you have no idea
I've got a fan for you
what's your name
what's your name Jacob now Jacob is a
very special device on his wrist tell me
what before you do
he built tell us about this it's a
functional web shooter I made with a 3d
printer
Wow
Jacob shoot him one more time
all right okay it's a prototype it's on
my foot right now
so wrap it up we'll come back to just a
bit but we got some super fans here
Nicky come on come over with me on to
the other side the hall
[Applause]
oh we got this what's your name
sir you can't I gotta you here where
were you from the bee bees
here who's your favorite adventure
Iron Man baby that's we're talking about
now while we're waiting for the car to
come in I am surprised to give away
right now
who wants some Infinity Gauntlet
[Applause]
I
gotta tell you thinking it is crazy in
here right now absolutely it's a
okay okay but the first car is gonna
arrive any minute now and you're gonna
be the first to see it all be there an
exhibit hall a okay so this is it if you
don't have any juice in your camera's
you need to be plugging that in now it
is happening essentially in just a few
seconds are gonna be coming down don't
forget the hashtags of the evening folks
hashtag infinity or of course hashtag
Avengers as G Marvel SG and of course
tankers at Marina Bay Sands at Marvel
Singapore as well okay so here's the
thing how secretive is this film that
this is probably honestly the most
top-secret more than the Pentagon more
than anything you can imagine because
like I said most of the actors haven't
read the full script some of the actors
were given fake pages writers had to
come up with about 15 different endings
you know why not for them for you to
preserve the integrity of the superfans
is that what we want yes that's what we
want right okay so that we're gonna
respect that we're gonna ask them all of
these questions but Bobby what's going
on is someone here what Nikki we're
waiting right now I see some headlights
behind the curtain I don't know what it
is yet
something's happening here it could be
any moment right now now the first cars
coming through is one after the party
changers
and executive producer Trent Ron and I
need you guys to make some noise because
this is gonna be the film of the air the
film of the decade are you guys ready
I'm Tony Nicky oh I need some water
all right the pay is coming here we go
[Applause]
right now Vicki I'm going over to the
event say to see you right now okay
we're going to see you back here and the
second out ladies and gent as you can
see coming through coming through one
half of the dynamic duo that directed
this incredible film Avengers infinity
war you get about to meet Joe Russo
brother about that really so and then
the executive producer of this
phenomenal motion picture trend tribe is
about to make their way onto the purple
carpet to me the very first fans
[Applause]
guys your lives to make some noise
reduced oh
[Applause]
what a dope the folks these two are
together when they come together they
make magic and magic we shall have there
they are meeting the fans who are some
of them from 3:00 a.m. 4:00 a.m. we
heard rumors of all these crazy types of
people came in so thank you so much for
showing them some love will welcome them
to the purple carpet down here in the
event plaza in just a few seconds
we are live facebook around the world to
make sure you are hash tagging please
infinity war avengers SG taggers
marvel's singapore and marina they said
here we go what's up dick hey
that was great that's crazy loud right
no crazy loud if you were crazy tell us
what's the energy like over there it is
amazing right now and the cars are all
coming in right now at the same time yes
yes yes oh my goodness okay so in a few
minutes are gonna be coming down and
like I said once they do hit the purple
carpet we're gonna take a breather
because I know the media have waited a
very long time and I know what it's like
to struggle for a soundbite okay we get
it so we're gonna take a breather during
that time but that is when everyone
needs to be taking photos and crazy up
on social media right so is about right
we got to Joe Russo and Trent Trent
coming down the purple carpet any moment
right now yeah I gotta tell you that
Rudy room is so excited to meet them to
meet everyone tonight when as part of
his massive family I mean he was saying
Joe Russo pretty much all of Hollywood
is in this film it makes some kind of
appearance so to try to schedule
everything for everyone was a mammoth
Herculean task and these two are
responsible plus their teams place and
they shot two films back-to-back
especially so I mean this is a mega
production to get here to shoot yeah
it's insane but you know what Joe Russo
when he first said even his brother
Anthony directed Winter Soldier who
remembers what your soldier
[Applause]
universe that was a completely different
movie and a whole different feel and it
was just great they got Robert Redford I
think I was like wow how does that
happen and then we had an event here
right we had an event here the last one
for civil war for civil war which we
thought was big I mean the main event
tonight
yes but didn't know like we said they've
been very secretive everyone is being
secretive lock and key to preserve the
integrity of this film especially
because in Singapore it comes out first
before the United States so we ask that
if you do be one of the first to see it
please don't spoil it for anyone else
you know you hate that especially the
age of social media where you say
where this goes be who could this be
oh oh let's see I don't have to
submission who knows who knows who do
you guys think this is Oh what
okay well we'll let it read we'll let it
breathe okay all right these are these
are their family and their friends
coming through okay good
oh
no I'm really excited for this I you
know and under lock and key but there
are a few things with we get to ask the
celebrities when they're on the stage
did you have a chance to see if there
was anything a burning question that a
fan had for a specific star yeah it was
a lot will you marry me will you marry
me
or you want to die as questions I
probably can't ask so what has to be
done Robert Downey jr. he likes to poppy
that's a very good question you know and
yeah if we get a chance to talk about
food and booty will I might ask her out
to potty but I don't think we'll have
that time there might be some other
serious questions but that the truth is
Robert Downey jr. has never been to
Singapore before this is his birth
boys when he shows up can you do that
um you know I was thinking we could try
something out okay but as we do have a
bit more time when Robert does come and
then he hits the stage and then he's you
know it's gonna be fanfare crowd goes
wild etc etc what if we tried doing
something for him that he has an
experience before as a crowd where we
say something to him that's actually in
concert what are you thinking cooking
something very very simple because
there's very many people hi Robert oh
do you know something if we say it in
unison he'll be pretty impressed let's
try it on our count three two one
okay if you please do it just like that
when we're life with you it's amazing
she's gonna have so much fun with you
baby so good okay we're gonna do that
we're gonna do that and we're also gonna
meet nebula we're gonna be nebula yes
dr. strange
here
keep it professional keep it
professional licking ears I was a crush
on so I might be like part of my hosting
jobs actually to catch her if she faints
thank you so much that's not awkward at
all we're not long at all we're gonna be
meeting then we'll have a chat with them
they have been doing some of the press
tour already for the past few days I
mean some of them came from England from
the United States from everywhere so
we'll make them feel welcome and we've
got the media here who have already met
them possibly earlier the past few days
so that's gonna be good where are our
media from shout out some countries
where'd you come from
hey PST Bao Zhu okay okay all right
where else
Venetia I and I also got Sam yg over
there shout out the same way achieve my
boy the who anybody from Indonesia
[Applause]
Thailand
India you oh yeah yeah oh that's
wonderful it's great in time wonderful
place
all around there were anyone from
Australia
right over there Australia jealous
people Chuck oh that's right he's from
the land of Thor I heard somebody say
that okay okay great okay so that
doesn't always work Sweden
and Singapore event in popular course
represented okay wonderful okay so soon
soon soon a few seconds from that we are
gonna see Joe Russo trend trend coming
down the purple carpet such as letting
you know media that's happening
imminently so if you want to get ready
cuz we are going to be a little bit
quiet during that time we're gonna be
showing you live footage as the
celebrities come in through exhibit hall
and as they step into the purple carpet
so we'll let this breathe and if you see
yourselves on camera you know what to do
fancam style be happy be smiley or
meaning them fine here they come right
now here they come
[Applause]
they are the signing autographs at your
photos
there's gonna be seven thousand people
here
know like George said earlier we haven't
done anything like this Lena Bates and
so no idea
wonderful see at Pace it pays to wait it
pays to wait all those hours to be right
over
[Music]
they do
so said the best Marvel fans are in
Singapore
quote-unquote because he was here a
couple years ago presumably yes and that
was a big event and reaches pathway to
be sense for that but tonight we keep
telling you this because there was a
reason for it I don't know they'll see
her before oh it's government
once they step on
all the way back
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to
nothing to have you carry we can't wait
to see you over here in the purple
carpet
of
Ages thank you so much for coming to
Singapore and we'll see you down here in
just a second
[Music]
yeah
can we trouble you
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies
coming into home a the keeper of that
time stone
[Applause]
[Music]
any stock itself
[Applause]
Oh
world's most epic fans right here right
now Marina Bay Sands thank you thank you
thank you for joining us tonight we
can't wait to see you out here and in
that Plaza
[Music]
[Applause]
and only
Benedict Cumberbatch
[Applause]
[Music]
how're we doing tonight
[Applause]
you look great celebrities oh my
goodness I think they were overwhelmed I
would be I think so - I think Singapore
made some noise tonight in a soda at
Southeast Asia as a whole that was fun
incredible are you ready for some more
actually me they've got a closer
personal ask some questions all that
jazz I'll get to you
ask our fans over here oh I'm sorry
we're hearing that you know that's okay
you know that they love you anyways
right you know they love you anyways I
would be overwhelmed with 4,000 people
wanting to ask me questions that's ain't
never got to happen but you know are you
guys excited to see them oh
hi oh hi so this is it remember what we
were practicing a while ago do you guys
remember let me drop this together
[Applause]
okay we got it - one two three
they're ready for that part yesterday
for that part okay so right now we are
waiting of course for our guests to
arrive here
remember all of you have your turn on
your LED wristbands right have you got
it hold on make sure they're turned on
we need them all on right now okay good
hey remember the hashtags whatever you
take a picture of tonight AB enters SG
infinity war Tigers the bar most
important of course we're gonna be a
sham and these guys to go up okay we're
gonna have drones in the air you're
gonna see yourself Singapore in a way
you have never seen yourselves before
for an absolute spectacle as we meet the
biggest stars of the biggest movies of
the year ten years in the making
no idea how they pulled out all the
stops fingers possible they're keeping
everything under lock and key we're
gonna do our best to add some questions
here okay we were gonna try we're gonna
try and get whatever we can out of it
but who knows the whole point is to
preserve the integrity of this film for
you fans are you fan
[Applause]
and how great this is aged look now this
is beautiful oh this is cool this is
sensational okay fantastic okay so we're
gonna be meeting them in any moment now
and I think we have so many questions we
want to ask and I know especially for
Joe I mean for his brother how exciting
it must be to do something so complex
you know these combustible relationships
between all these heroes coming together
well he has a practice with civil war
yes which I could say is about maybe
Avengers 2.5 have to say that right yeah
but now I'm hearing those 50-plus
characters of this movie
for a year for a year for a year we know
what go Nicky yep it started 10 years
ago how many of you remember the extra
scene after iron man
[Music]
oh
that gave me goosebumps because that was
the start of something we've never seen
in cinema before the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in a way that only comic book
fans have dreamed of and now came
together we get to see this in nine days
time
the United States of America so what
happens when you watch this film what do
you tell people
vanos demands your silence you do not
want to mess with Thanos okay this is
the most evil villain in the galaxy you
do not mess with phantoms Eddie's got
two very angry daughters yes one of them
is here tonight Yala daddy issues which
we will explore if we have time with her
on this stage but you know what I'm
thinking of how many of you are in the
camp that I am in that star-lord
actually has more powers than we think
[Music]
[Applause]
of course she's a special right happens
less sure now they say he lost his
powers at Gaul you too but did he really
lose his powers you can hold an infinity
stone right so that means that means he
is powerful and he unleashes it if he
knows how to do it if he actually has
the powers he could be a hidden talent
in the Avengers team that nobody thinks
about it could be star-lord I'm just
putting that out there I have no idea by
the way who knows again a lot of these
actors even different turrets not one
particular person so we believe actually
knows how this all comes together
especially if they film two films
back-to-back but guess what we found out
what when do we find out you tell me
what did we find out really nobody's
read the full script yeah they made a
lot of extra scenes they wrote a lot of
extra scenes for the cast and they
thought they'd read the real script but
they didn't they throw a spanner in the
mix that is the whole point and they
wouldn't let Tom Holland read anything I
think would you know I am so excited to
see Tom Holland do this all right
absolutely you know who was great and he
was saying they were doing a few
interviews for them in England when they
were promoting the film and he said what
he liked the most about working with his
cast as he was never meant to feel like
he was the new kid on the block you know
he was a new cast member but they were
family so with that I think we're ready
to go are you ready to rumble
are you ready
first special guest here but first take
a look at the screen to see his latest
creation
[Music]
[Applause]
to wipe out half the universe
to all the Infinity stones do it with
the snap of his fingers
[Applause]
[Music]
talk like this playing here's I think
it's good except
[Music]
I hope they remember you
I'm spider-man
[Music]
[Applause]
behind the camera half of the amazing
team who directed Avengers infinity war
though on the only
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you joke with the director of
the question you say hey
thank you thanks so much to keep up I
really appreciate thank you for coming
and I want to get a lot of
[Applause]
guys to be back here again and to see so
many of you here tonight
and it's a beautiful night
I am incredibly
so I just wanna let everybody know that
I have I've been secretly planning with
the Disney team putting together an
evening of unexpected thrills and
surprises I
gotta tell you we can't wait to get
started let's do it John alright well so
and I've done a great job keeping our
incredible fans entertaining this
evening we can't thank you enough I know
many of you been waiting patiently for a
few hours may be the one that's some of
them all day how about we get started to
get on with the show
[Applause]
secret planning for you tonight at the
event but did you know that every film
behind every film there are hundreds
even thousands of people involved in it
and making that film come to life and
making that from great and I am
delighted that one of those those very
very important people we say able to
join us tonight
our next guest needs little introduction
super fans like all of you she's the
executive producer for Avengers infinity
war please please give a very warm
welcome to Trent Ram
[Applause]
hey trying
to get together you make magic like
we've never seen so we're just so
thrilled thank you really thank you it's
just that tell me is this your first
time visiting Singapore first time I've
never been here before
[Applause]
you know everybody boobies : well a flag
as well thank you so much for that here
we get rid of Singapore welcome please
train once you tell us why vengers
infinity war is so special well this is
the 19th Marvel movie 10 years in the
making and it's a culmination film of
all the characters from 18 movies
leading up to this so this is a very
special film and you know I can't wait
for audience to really experience all of
the characters coming together in this
movie this is why this movie is so
unique when all the characters really
come together and and really you know
fight against the biggest baddest Marvel
villain in the history battles that's
right Thanos is coming why don't we tell
only tell the audience here tonight how
hard we worked you and I worked and my
brother worked and the writers worked to
keep this film secret
well
ten more days right we've been very
protective of this particular movie you
know more so than ever
and you know even to the point where we
were creating fake versions of the
script so that no one can accidentally
spoil any of the you know plots
and I think especially for this we just
wanted to you know make sure that
audience actually share in the
experience at the same time and watch it
together exactly so thank you so much
for joining us tonight trend how that
she worked so
all right now some time yeah working on
these large-scale films is like being in
a war or about you got to have your
battle gear on and be ready for anything
now I mean every inch of the warrior you
are
gentlemen
yes you've seen her in guardians of the
galaxy volume 1 and volume 2 two
daughters battles and the sister
you know where is nebula
[Applause]
Dillon
[Music]
[Applause]
some of the nurses last night
Karen tell us tell us how
I just it's such an honor to be involved
in a movie like this I mean it's just so
large and scale it's the biggest
superhero movie ever I'm gonna go ahead
and say I just can't believe that I was
in it in any capacity it was amazing and
you have a really interesting story
about how you became part of the Marvel
Universe when you share that with the
truck tonight did you have to go to any
great lengths oh
you did
yeah so basically I am local for my
agent and they were like are you willing
to shave your head and I was like what
for and they said horrible that I was
like absolutely so I didn't even know
what the role was and then I got the
role and I was so excited and then I
realized I was gonna have to be
completely bald to play in Nebula so I
shaved off all my hair which was very
long and I got on video you took a video
oh yes a video
but mean Marvel are amazing they made me
a wig of my own hair which I sometimes
wear for comedic purposes
it's really creepy
guys she's incredible in the movie
thinking that
[Applause]
something's happening
now it's up to stage two
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the sorcerer
supreme himself
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just incredible it's awesome just
[Applause]
want to thank all the fans who have been
still here some very young
[Applause]
why does dr. strange the sorceress
supreme that's so important about the
nervous I think because she kind of
guards our reality he's a parenthesis
this bracket of what we know if the
world we've lived in a kind of
real dimensional
live action a sequential sort of Hell
now
things have got a lot better I know
[Applause]
so yeah he's um he's meditators well you
know he just does things are truly
extraordinary in the multiverse and the
threats replacing minestrone contain a
direction that is
[Music]
Robert Downey jr. and Tom
[Applause]
they're great guys and very generous and
fun and you know Rob's our King I detest
the king and you know his empires of
over nine one his rule is for he benign
he's very generous sharing and caring
and he's just a really good laugh and
brilliant at his job to watch him do
what he does is of true inspirations you
know and he keeps us smiling it's a
happy day on set when he's around and
what what's your experience been like so
far here in Singapore no mullahs nobody
there to me we've returned another film
at the same time you know so we've got
to know each other quite well but um
he's smashing 21 no he's much wiser than
sometimes it is and I learned from him
as well it contains a huge amount of
tannin and ease yes my eyes beyond his
years and to watch Illinois DJ's fo and
that relationship that paternal things
just a fantastic thing for advances or -
well Benedict Karen trend thank you so
much for being here tonight I know the
fans are very appreciative I
[Applause]
think as we look around
missing
[Applause]
[Music]
very welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
both of the Singapore
we did practice something earlier which
we tried to do in concert especially for
you do you remember what we practiced
3 2 1
[Applause]
yeah that's got to be one of the best
welcomes with Abraham
[Applause]
it's been a heck of a journey to
you ten years
tell us proud ones like looking back on
the first Iron Man film from we're here
about
well obviously we're getting a little
more attention than reviews and as
always we talked about this all the time
it's about how the
the fellowship of
like-minded creatives
but uh I
[Applause]
was here two years ago with civil war I
said I absolutely have to come back to
Singapore thinfinity war
[Applause]
Robert these guys have to look for a
team to without anything anywhere well
Joe when are you gonna show us the
script
that BP shooting scenes blind we don't
know what they might be
yeah listen you come on my hotel room
later a chant all you want
[Applause]
right now as far as I'm concerned well
she's the boss but he's the one in
charge so I'm gonna listen to him and I
asked Benedict what it was like working
with you why don't you tell us a little
bit what it was like we're gonna bet on
it
you know what I hate to say that I'm
sorry Mark Ruffalo the science froze
babies
[Applause]
get ready
all right 15 Bobby I think we're gonna
do a little bit of a cue in anything
yeah I've got a question for each of the
characters yeah okay here we go out of
all the Marvel characters of the
cinematic universe which one has the
power to defeat Thanos
is there one
the
whole point of the Avengers is a team
coming together to despite their
differences to overcome impossible odds
so I think well I think it's gonna take
all of the team on this one okay in
someone I wanted to ask Robert you said
a couple days ago at the press
conference obviously when you have
success do not repeat that formula that
is the point at the end of the day but
you feel that you guys with Avengers
infinity war have hit the nail on the
head had you've nailed it why do you
think you guys have nailed it
well I mean we always look for feedback
starting with comic-con in
2007 well the fans were telling us what
you did with this first Ironman believe
that we think that's what we like and we
it's been a back-and-forth ever since
peers might guess cuz I haven't read the
script because
Jeremy Renner's not in the poster I
think he's the only one that can be
so literally I think only Jeremy can be
seen haha
some holland terrible splendid I know he
was josh brolin ever on stats or was it
just talking to a tennis ball the entire
time I never saw him never hit
he was on set or did a lot of work that
said yeah you know as intimidating as
Josh can be in his performances in the
movie I think he looked fairly
ridiculous for most of the time because
he had a wearing giant headpiece and
very large
chest piece that made him look a little
bit yeah
they told us the same height I guess I
just have one last question for for the
three actors here tonight is you've
worked on large scale productions you
have incredible repertoire in your
arsenal but what makes Avengers infinity
war truly unique to you and your Germany
as an actor
ladies first I'm gonna say it might be
the lunches
all together and we all socialize and he
gives us the most beautiful
[Music]
that's that's why the budgets not
balloon
the fans
[Applause]
um you know and I think the fact that
this is very familiar like Robert said
it they don't sit on their laurels
Marvel Studios it's about blessing it
every single time making it better with
funny a different I knew I knew we were
doing something
I
don't say taxon it required more of us
because we shoot C's and then Toby like
I looked at it we're gonna try a
different way of doing it we just shot
that seat we've got all these overseas
you go I got a better idea and it wound
up always improving its that we were
improving it as we went along and then
if I have a 30-second break Trin would
be saying hey listen we got this thing
we need to do some like five lines of
ADR I was like I was I was gonna go to
the bathroom
should I do that she goes you should
definitely do this
all right look it's been an incredible
night and we want to thank all the fans
that have come out here this evening
on Facebook live across the region
that's one Facebook live right now
before we go I'm looking to have you out
there in the audience for your help with
one one last thing now we all know that
fairness is looking for the Infinity
stones right and there is one stone that
still needs to reveal
so stunning right all right well it's
one of the directions of the film I was
able to influence its location
[Applause]
and that location
its pocket now it's right here in
Singapore
[Applause]
Nikki Bobby it's not the Sun itself
but you'll see what I mean when you
watch this and as I've said earlier
we've worked really really hard with the
team on something very special day on
tonight's event I'm not gonna ask all of
you out there everyone I want you to
hold up both your arms in the air
together
pull them both up all right I want you
to say Avengers Assemble you're writing
on account of great one two three
we got to see it a little louder than
that if they want this to happen all
right for you this one more time ready
one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
we love you
[Applause]
Teru so
Wow how is that a probable thank you so
much for joining us tonight I think
everyone wants to take pictures this is
it this is the moment I tried to wear em
across all I know we have our guests
Tucker finish the stage right now we
another grant coming for crowd shots
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you this come on fans here we go
I see my turn up at 500 yards two men
responsible for tonight's to come on
stage for some photos right now
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
fantastic
thank you come on
[Applause]
[Music]
our laws
slobs
[Music]
George - George so trip train turned
down
[Applause]
Wow
based on tonight I'm going to show you
tonight
the entire Bay
to the bulbous to the magic universe
[Music]
take photos
[Applause]
the
pilots
thank you for coming
you know about regionally and together
we share oh good choice
[Applause]